in front of the assembled press
president Trump signed an executive
order imposing new sanctions against
Iran the order is meant to limit access
to financial resources for Iran's
supreme leader Ayatollah Khomeini and
his associates we will continue to
increase pressure on terrorists until
the regime abandons its dangerous
activities and aspirations including the
pursuit of nuclear weapons increased
enrichment of uranium development of
ballistic missiles engagement in and
support for terrorism fuelling of
foreign conflicts and belligerent acts
directed against the United States and
its allies the reason given for the
additional sanctions a US drone shut
down by Iran Tehran says the rationale
was fabricated the US government also
accuses Iranian Revolutionary Guards of
attacking merchant ships in the Strait
of Hormuz according to the u.s. more
than 80 percent of the Iranian economy
is already affected by sanctions the
Trump administration wants to force the
leadership in Tehran to agree to a new
nuclear agreement with tougher
conditions Trump also reiterated an
offer for new negotiations he claims
Iran could become a peaceful and
prosperous country if it were to abandon
its pursuit of nuclear weapons
well the standoff between the United
States and Iran was addressed at the UN
Security Council last night the council
called for maximum restraint while the
u.s. urged Iran to negotiate with
Germany with Washington rather Germany's
Ambassador warned of the risk of
tensions escalating further French
Germany and the United Kingdom are
gravely concerned by the increased
tensions in the Gulf that were further
heightened after the downing of a US
drone by Iran on the 20th of June these
developments risk miscalculation and
conflict we call for de-escalation and
dialogue with full respect for
international rules so Germany appealing
for dialogue there at the UN but Iran's
UN Ambassador said the atmosphere was
not right for dialogue to happen between
Tehran and Washington you cannot start a
dialogue with somebody who is
threatening you who is intimidating you
today we just witness that the United
States imposed another set of sanctions
against Iran how can we start a dialogue
with somebody whose primary
preoccupation is to put more sanctions
on Iran so the atmosphere of such a
dialogue does is not ready yet as the
u.s. of course imposing those sanctions
US National Security Advisor John Bolton
said Washington nonetheless was willing
to enter into talks with Iran at the
same time the president has held the
door open to real negotiations they
completely verifiable eliminate Iran s
nuclear weapons program its pursuit of
ballistic missile delivery systems its
support for international terrorism u.s.
national security advisor john bolton
there well he made those comments at a
meeting in Jerusalem with his
counterparts from Israel and Russia Iran
is set to feature prominently on the
agenda for the talks between those
representatives today for more let's
cross over live to our correspondent in
Jerusalem Tanya Kramer Tanya what can we
expect from these talks in Jerusalem
well as you said it's kind of an
unprecedented meeting between the three
national security advisors from Israel
from Russia and from the US and Prime
Minister Netanyahu has said that he will
do everything to prevent Iran from
obtaining nuclear weapons but also from
entrenching itself in neighboring Syria
so we're expecting these talks mainly to
talk about the Iranian influence in the
region of course about the latest
tensions as well between the u.s. and
Iran and of course about Iran's row
in ceará which is very much of concern
to Israel also for Prime Minister
Netanyahu it is very important to give a
message to the region that he is part of
those talks that he's a partner for
these talks among these two big nations
Russia and the US now Israel sees Iran
is a threat the u.s. increasingly so as
well but Russia is somewhere else do you
see any prospect in these talks of
Russia aligning itself with the
positions of Israel in the u.s.
concerning Iran well from a point of
view from Israel Russia is a very
important player especially when it
comes to a Syria Russia is close to Iran
but also close to the Assad regime so
there has been very close cooperation
between Russia and Israel when it comes
to carrying out airstrikes on behalf of
from the Israelis in on military targets
in Syria
there are there's coordination going on
with that but on the other hand it's
also very ambivalent role as you said so
the question here in these talks is how
far is Russia prepared to go and what
they will actually ask in return when it
comes to containing Iran and its
entrenchment in Syria and this is really
the most important question here also
for the Israelis Tanya thank you very
much for that GWS correspondent Tanya
Kramer in Jerusalem